what do you think is the most difficult
aspect of building a civilization on
mars terraforming mars like from
engineering perspective from a financial
perspective
human perspective to get
to get a large number of folks there
who will never return back to earth
uh no they could certainly return some
will return back to earth they will
choose to stay there for the rest of
their lives yeah many will um
but uh we you know we
we need the spaceships back like the
ones that go to mars read them back so
you can hop on if you want you know it's
like but we can't just not have the
spaceships come back those things are
expensive we need them i'd like to come
back and do another trip i mean do you
think about the terraforming aspect like
actually building are you so focused
right now on the spaceships part that's
so critical yeah this is
we absolutely if you can't get there
nothing else matters
so
and like i said
we can't get there with
at some extraordinarily high cost i mean
the current cost of
um let's say
one ton to the surface of mars is on
order of a billion dollars
so
because you don't just need the rocket
and the launch and everything you need
like heat shield you need you know
guidance system you need uh deep space
communications uh you need some kind of
landing system
so like rough approximation would
uh be
billion dollars per ton to the surface
of mars right now
um this is obviously
um
way too expensive to create a
self-sustaining civilization
um
so we need to improve that by
at least a factor of a thousand
a million per ton
yes ideally less than much less than a
million ton but if it's not
like it's got to be
you see you have to say like what well
how much can
society afford to spend or want to just
want to spend on a self-sustaining city
on mars the self-sustaining part is
important like it's just the key
threshold
um the great filter
will will have been passed when
the city on mars
it can survive even if the spaceships
from earth stop coming for any reason it
doesn't matter what the reason is but if
they stop coming for any reason will it
die out will it not and if there's even
one critical ingredient missing then
it still doesn't count it's like
you know if you're on a long sea voyage
and you've got everything except vitamin
c
and it's only a matter of time you know
you're going to die
so
so we're going to get mars amorous city
to the point where it's self-sustaining
um i'm not sure this will really happen
in my lifetime but i i hope to see it at
least have a lot of momentum
and and then you could say okay what is
the minimum tonnage necessary to uh have
a self-sustaining city
um
and there's a lot of uncertainty about
this you could say like i don't know
it's probably at least a million tons
um
because you have to set up a lot of
infrastructure on on mars
like i said you can't be missing any
anything that
in order to be self-sustaining you can't
be missed like you need you know
semiconductor
fabs you need
iron ore refineries like you need lots
of things you know
so um and mars is not super hospitable
it's it's the least inhospitable planet
but it's definitely a fixer-upper of a
planet outside of earth
yes the earth is like easy
yeah and also we should clarify in the
solar system yes in the solar system
there might be nice
like vacation spots there might be some
great planets out there but
it's hard to get there yeah way way way
way too hard
you